hey leute erst mal vor weihnachten hallo
hier ich bin luca und ich wollte euch
nur sagen dass meine website nun online
ist konkreter punkt.de der link steht
ganz oben in der beschreibung wird auch
weiterhin unter allen videos in der
beschreibung stehen steht auch schon auf
meinen kanal und fuhr weiter und so fort
ich habe jetzt hier einfach nur seinen
black screen eingefügt werde jetzt einen
kleinen frame seht wie die website
aussieht aber nur einen ganz kleinen
frame okay hier nochmal da habt ihr noch
mal und zwar sollte einfach auf die
website gehen und euch selber eine
meinung von der website bilden sage ich
mal weh saßen nun jetzt ungefähr
anderthalb monate an der website eine
bearbeitung aber es ist einfach clowns
machen wir drei monate voll noch mal
alles umgeschmissen immer ein bisschen
anders gemacht
und na ja also wir sind dominik und ich
dominik hilft mir bei der ganzen html
sachen und ich mache halt die ganzen
grafiken für die website war ich mich
mit html halt kein bisschen auskennen
bzw
ich kann den text schreiben und den dann
fett machen und ein bild im hintergrund
und der tabelle machen und bleibe mehr
auch nicht
also nur so komisches in form informatik
zeugs da was man damals in der schule
halt gelernt hat so ein schwachsinn oder
kann er schon deutlich gut und die
komplette website deshalb kein template
sondern alles selber gescriptet und da
bin ich auf jeden fall sehr dankbar
deswegen haben wir auf der website auch
ein wenig werbung geschaltet und zwar
wenn man auf die werbung drauf kriegt
man kriegen wir natürlich geld wodurch
dann die website weiterhin finanziert
wird und so weiter und so fort und zwar
kostet ja der server auch ein bisschen
worüber die website läuft und 2000 ford
habe ich ja alle schon gesagt also würde
ich einfach sagen geht auf die website
bildet euch eine eigene meinung und
außerdem es ist ja gerade 16 uhr wenn
dieses video seht also um 16 lustiges
video herausgekommen am 24 dezember 16
uhr 2012 und heute abend um 18 uhr kommt
die neue folge christmas kraft also die
24 folge die letzte folge dort gibt es
noch diese sechs gewinner die da noch
die spieler gewonnen haben und dann
würde ich einfach sagen um 18 uhr wird
dann auch der download von der christmas
kraft welt auf meiner website an
freigeschaltet und die website ist
einfach dafür da dazu da dass ich dort
eventuell bald live streams machen kann
also dass eine live stream verlinkung
dort werden werde ich immer meine ganzen
videos verlinken dort könnt ihr euch
sachen runterladen wie zum beispiel die
alte testament welt die treffer show
wählten da werdet ihr dann zu den
websites weitergeleitet oder
die jetzt die christmas kraft welt gibt
es da da gibt es dann auch noch solche
sachen wie zb ein faq wo ihr dann seht
so ok der macht kein together mit mir
weil deswegen und deswegen und so also
das ist schon eine ganz gute sache und
da könnt ihr dann einfach drauf gemeinde
paar informationen über mich haben
wollte und dann würde ich einfach sagen
jedoch die website bietet euch eine
eigene meinung und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal tschüss